before creation itself there were six
singularities
forged into Infinity stones hey
everybody it's Charlie hopefully you've
had a chance to see Black Panther I've
gotten a lot of requests for a soulstone
video if you've never seen me before
you're brand new to the channel there is
an Infinity Gauntlet replica giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so just careful for
spoilers if you have not seen Black
Panther yet you may have seen the
director Ryan Coogler talking about the
Infinity stones because he's a huge
Marvel Comics or just like James Gunn
big comic book nerds loves the Infinity
stones but here's him talking about
Infinity stones specific to the Black
Panther movie and I do not think that
he's trying to be misleading I think
he's being as honest as possible
I love that finish tall as much as any
comic book fan you know it's just what
kind of kinda hazards are already
hazards thing which is vibranium um for
us died without was special enough so
sort of throwing something like another
special thing didn't didn't feel right
you know you know it felt like you know
we should we should sushi stick with
thought with our one kind of MacGuffin
for the country explore that let that be
the important day you know in because we
didn't need even frankly didn't need to
have it so when he says that there are
no Infinity stones in Wakanda people are
mostly thinking about the soul stone
just because that's the last one that's
left Black Panther was the last
opportunity before infinity war to
introduce it his reason being that
vibranium is a special enough MacGuffin
like we barely scratched the surface
with that now based on new information
it does actually seem like Thanos really
will collect all six during infinity war
meaning that we're not gonna have to
wait till Avengers four to find out
where the soul stone is but for all the
things that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has changed about the origin of
the Infinity stones the Russos are doing
a version of the comic book version of
the soul stone now the roster of
characters is a little bit different but
some of the comic book twists when
Thanos was collecting all six of the
gems during phantos quest are important
so that's really the only thing you need
to understand is like some of the big
twists and what it is that the soul
stone actually does we know a little bit
about
powers of all the different stones the
soul stone is different because it
allows you to literally control the
souls of people as if the soul was a
separate entity like you sort of get a
taste for that during Black Panther when
they're on the ancestral plane and both
kill monger and Black Panther are
speaking to their respective father
spirits this sort of Marvel's way of
invoking the literal soul but that
doesn't have anything to do with the
actual location of the soul gem
we've talked a little bit about the
actual story of Thanos quest what it
seems like the Russos have done is is
they put the soul stone in a location
that's very similar to the location that
it was during the Thanos quest storyline
albeit with a change of characters like
I said the roster is a little bit
different but if you haven't read a
Thanos quest is the story where death
brings Thanos back to life and empowers
him to balance the universe which is
basically what Galactus does on a much
smaller scale Thanos needs to do it on a
universal scale all instantaneously
which is why he has to collect all the
gems in the gauntlet when he starts that
quest the very first stone that he goes
after is the soul stone is in the
possession of the in-betweener
who isn't really a Marvel Cinematic
Universe character so you don't need to
totally understand who he is he's a
powerful cosmic being who at the time
has been imprisoned in this nexus
between chaos and order in an alternate
dimension while he still possesses the
soul gem
so first dannis needs to free him but
the soul stone is actually fairly
powerful so he has to trick the gem away
from him which he does then he goes on
his way to collect the power gem but
remember the movie is changing the order
in which he goes after the gems I've
already done a couple videos about that
so it's not quite as important for the
location of the soul gem only the idea
that in the movie the soul stone is
trapped in another reality that's
inaccessible at the beginning of the
film with their current resources so
again sort of looping in the importance
of Doctor Strange his movie was
important for a lot of reasons and not
just the fact that he has the time gem
which is a really big deal but the idea
of all these alternate realities like we
dealt with Dormammu in the Dark
Dimension that's one of many realities
so the main purpose of that is just to
introduce you to the concept that there
are things that live in other realities
the soul stone during Thanos quest the
soul stone during the infinity war movie
also trapped in another
[Music]
the next important piece of the puzzle
is what the soul gem actually does so
like I said the Russos even though
they've changed a couple of the
characters in a couple of the ways the
twists work out they're still trying to
follow the comic book story of the soul
stone and in the comics it's kind of
vampiric like it actually steals
people's souls when you stack its powers
with the other gems it allows you to
control the souls of everyone in the
universe simultaneously the new theory
states that the reason why they're
saving the soul gem for the end of the
movie is one keeping in mind that thus
far in the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
Infinity stones have been used as
MacGuffins like themselves kind of
important but not as important for the
story of each of the movies
just something to drive you forward like
oh we got to get that next gem that's
not gonna change during infinity war
it's gonna be galactic Pokemon as he
tries to collect all the gems by the end
of the film so naturally structuring a
story the final gem won't be collected
til the end of the movie and he'll need
all the power of the stones to collect
that last one which is trapped in an
alternate reality but also in the fact
that the soul stone steals the souls of
other people fan OHS will have to feed
it a soul in order to control it we've
had a lot of theories about who's gonna
die during these movies just remember
that they are doing a version of the
comics Thanos will eventually change
reality the Avengers will have to fix it
so you can bet that there will be people
that will die and then be brought back
to life when the Avengers fix everything
now obviously I think we're all
wondering if anybody's gonna still be
dead after it's all over but just
talking about infinity war and
collecting that soul stone if you need a
soul to control it Thanos will have to
sacrifice someone so that character will
die then probably be brought back after
the Avengers fix everything
Thanos collects the gems and that even
though it's still a theory I think all
of us comic-book readers are an
agreement that infinity war ends with
the infamous comic book finger-snap
Thanos changes reality and that
everybody in the audience screams at the
same time while we have to wait for
infinity war to find out how the
surviving Avengers are going to
everything in what Thanos's new version
of reality is going to look like which
is why it's important that they're
releasing Avengers for next year like
they don't want to make you wait two
years after seeing a nose change all of
reality so just a quick recap soulstone
not in the possession of any of the
characters that we've seen so far not
secretly hid inside the vibranium
meteorite I'm taking the director at his
word that when he says there's no
infinity stone it's not hidden anywhere
in Black Panther in plain sight like
it's literally in another dimension
somewhere else that we'll see during
infinity war and it will be the final
one that they nose collects which also
throws into question some of this
behind-the-scenes stuff here because
there's a couple of gems missing from
this gauntlet here so don't worry we're
gonna be getting some more infinity war
footage soon but let me know what do you
think about the idea of the Russos doing
a version of Thanos quest in the soul
stone for the actual movie
congratulations to the latest Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway winner Joel G please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
when I post new Marvel obviously there's
lots of infinity war we need to talk
about so just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below next one
will probably be for the Black Order in
the Cole obsidian while you wait for
everything click here to learn about
Black Panther - Chris Evans even
confirmed the Black Widow movie and you
can click here to learn about brand new
flash and Titans thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]